I'm non shonda editor of Elle global
online we are very pleased to have with
us in our studio our Nicholas Burns the
former Undersecretary of State for
political affairs and currently the
professor of practice of diplomacy and
international relations at Harvard's
Kennedy School of Government welcome
thanks very much nine so I'm so
delighted that you are here with us
today having covered the whole world for
the State Department until a year ago
you are perhaps one of the steel and
leading experts on major issues roiling
us so why don't you give us just in
nutshell as to what do you think the
major challenges faced by President
Obama today major international
challenges well ngayon thank you very
much for the invitation to be here at
Yale and be part of the Yale global
online series i would say that President
Obama as as the new American president
faces an extraordinary number of
challenges and the degree of difficulty
that he will have in meeting these
challenges is truly forbidding I support
him and wish him well but if you think
about what is on his diplomatic plate
right now obviously the most prominent
issue is the global economic crisis he
is spending it seems most of his time on
that which he should he's just come
through a meeting of the g20 leaders in
London which made some progress in
empowering the IMF to deal with aspects
of this crisis but I think we're still
waiting to see the full dimensions of a
coherent aggressive international
response to the crisis I do feel that
President Obama has made the right steps
here in the United States with his
stimulus package and with the bailout
packages for both our financial
institutions and now for our automobile
companies but clearly there's much more
that needs to be done both in America
and overseas and that has to be his
first priority as a global leader but if
you look beyond the global crisis to see
the daunting foreign policy agenda that
he inherited from president george w
bush i don't think we've seen such a
difficult form well what a woman did not
only time three most important
challenges that he faces apart from the
financial crisis I
well I'd say that first of all he needs
to continue to cope with the two wars
that were fighting in Iraq and
Afghanistan he's laid out a very good
plan for a timetable to withdraw
American troops from Iraq it's going to
be difficult obviously to do that in a
way that tries to maintain stability in
Iraq but of course that's the intention
I think he has a greater challenge in
Afghanistan where the war is heating up
where the Taliban and al-qaeda have been
more aggressive and perhaps even more
effective unfortunately over the last
several months and years and he's going
to add American troops but also try to
effect a greater counter a more coherent
counterinsurgency strategy I would think
those two wars would be a first priority
second would be global climate change
the United States did not participate in
the Kyoto regime we are now pledged to
participate oh but President Obama says
we will in the Copenhagen process that's
a very good step to put America back in
to the middle of the international
debate as a participant as one of the
leading carbon emitters and historically
is the largest carbon emitter and it's a
welcome step and I hope it does restore
some of the credibility that we lost as
a country because we were not
participating in what most people around
the world felt was a global priority and
third I'd say there's a complex of
issues out there that are really global
if you will transnational in nature and
they cannot be met by the United States
alone they cannot be met by a country
that's either isolationist or unilateral
ists they have to be met by an America
engaging with the other leading
countries in the world everything from
from international narcotics cartels and
crime cartels we're seeing some of that
on the Mexican US border now to the
fight against pandemics to the fight
against terrorism to the fight against
nuclear proliferation the trafficking
women and children and of course by to
see and of course piracy we've seen that
very dramatically off off the Horn of
Africa in recent weeks this complex of
transnational issues is going to require
an unprecedented level of international
cooperation and it means that all of us
have to be multilateral and think
multilateral and I think President Obama
is heading in that direction
so this this lathrop challenges that you
just outlined they are so disparate in
nature and how is this department or US
government is organized to deal with
this very disparate measure of
challenges well some of these challenges
some of them like piracy or terrorism in
part can be dealt with through strong a
strong military in the Horn of Africa
now in the Indian Ocean we've seen a
high degree of cooperation among the
NATO countries and countries like China
beyond NATO all working together to try
to police the sea lane so that the
world's traffic the world's goods can be
can be channel through their very safely
without the threat of piracy some but
some of them have to be confronted and I
think probably most of them that are
transnational in character by diplomacy
by broad broad based diplomacy either
through traditional cooperation among
countries or through foreign assistance
programs and here I think the United
States needs to strengthen this
diplomatic corps and needs to strengthen
its capacity to be active diplomatically
I guess relative to the rest of the
world we have a very large diplomatic
corps but relative to our own military
it's quite small and I think any country
has to balance its hard and soft power
and the instruments available to it to
be effective and I think the challenge
for the United States at this stage is
to port more money and attention into
diplomacy as a first line of offense
rather than a last resort I think yeah I
think you had mentioned in our little
cushion that the United States diplomats
number of diplomats are actually smaller
than musicians in the US military band
right it's a lamentable fact that there
are more musicians in the Armed Forces
band of the US Army Navy Air Force and
Marines then there are American
diplomats someone even told me there are
more lawyers in the pentagon american
diplomats if you know if that's the case
then clearly we've got to reorder our
national priorities so that our
diplomatic power is equal to our
military power or at least equal
attention is given to it because i do
think
well any country and certainly a country
like ours needs a strong military and I
don't want to see our military weekend I
do think that we have to understand that
the majority of the challenges that the
globe is facing and will face in the
future do not always lend themselves to
military action they more often lend
themselves to the type of work that
we're trying to do for instance on
hiv/aids prevention in so in Africa or
in Haiti in this hemisphere or the
anti-poverty programs in Brazil or in
India and and you need people who are
trained in that aspect of international
work not just to train in war fighting
let's stay movement it on the by this
issue the piracy seems to me is the
Morris symptom of a serious problem than
the cause of the current problem in in
in and Horn of Africa Somalia is a
failed state and people have no jobs
apparently fish has been depleted by
foreign fishing vessels in Somalian
waters saving the fishermen have
difficulty making a living and in this
situation they are taking to piracy not
because of an ideological reason but for
pure economy reasons so by simply
sending gunboats there are you going to
solve the problem well I think you
probably have to put together the global
community will have to put together a
combination of short-term measures and
longer-term measures in the short term
despite the fact that people may be poor
and of course people are suffering in a
very weak fragile failed state as you
say such as Somalia but that is no
justification to turning towards to
turning to piracy which is of course a
barbaric practice from one thinks of it
from another age from the 18th century
more than the 21st century and it's um
it's obviously illegal internationally
it puts people's lives in jeopardy as
you've seen it very dramatically just
over the last couple of days and so one
hand to speak out against piracy and
convince the Somalis practicing it that
it's wrong and that they should cease
and desist
on but of course in the long term I
think you're right to suggest that we
also have to look at the conditions
which would produce this lamentable
state of affairs Somalia is one of the
least governed or at least well-governed
countries on earth it sits at a series
of failed governments and therefore it
is the responsibility in part of the
international community to try to help
us in whatever way we can to see a more
stable more responsible more law-abiding
government in Somalia that won't be a
refuge for terrorist groups as Somalia
has been in the past and continues to be
and certainly won't be a haven for
pirates who prey upon commercial
shipping in the world you know we think
of globalization maybe the
personification of it is the jetliner
but much more of the world's goods food
aid for poor people and oil and gas are
and exports that countries depend upon
they depend on sea traffic and so safe
commerce in the seas free of piracy is
an international good and therefore the
world needs to speak out against the
pirates but also as you suggest do
something in the longer term to make
sure this problem can disappear da Cunha
what failed state Afghanistan
Afghanistan became the aboard of al
Qaeda because this had become a failed
state and now President Obama is trying
to win in Afghanistan by sending more
troops is that going to do it well i
think you know to be fair to president
obama he sees a NATO alliance that is
not succeeding in Afghanistan he said
during the campaign us and has said
since becoming president that
Afghanistan is in effect round zero in
the American fight against Al Qaeda al
Qaeda was harbored by the Taliban
infamously so before at nine eleven we
had to act rightfully to dislodge elcott
in the Taliban from power in Afghanistan
and so I think he's right to turn to it
and say that we cannot fail there we
have to succeed at least in blunting the
impact of the Taliban offensive on the
Afghan government and we need to put in
place a comprehensive policy and I think
could be fair to him he said yeah
we need to add troops some for combat in
the south and southern and eastern parts
of the country some for training of the
Afghan National Army but we also need to
add money and assistance and rule of law
programs and help to the United Nations
and NGO efforts to help the villagers of
Afghanistan that quite rural country to
survive this extraordinarily difficult
situation so it's a combination of
military and economic measures which
together might form an effective
counterinsurgency strategy that's the
bet that he's making and I think that he
I think that he's right to suggest that
this more holistic approach is the only
possible road towards success and I
support what he's doing the Taliban in
Afghanistan do you see them different
from Taliban in Pakistan because
President Obama has indicated that he is
willing to talk to some moderate
Sullivan in Afghanistan but I do not see
that the case in Pakistan is there a
difference if I think it's an enormously
complicated problem and I don't pretend
to be an expert on the Taliban in on
both sides of the border I would say
this it seems to me that it would not be
logical to talk to the leadership of the
Taliban at this point people like mullah
omar because they are the heart of the
problem and the source of a terrorism
that is being inflicted mainly upon the
ashton the pashtun population on both
sides of the border the
pakistan-afghanistan military it may be
possible we'll have to see for the
Afghans themselves the Afghan government
to launch some kind of a program that
would encourage rank-and-file Taliban to
give up their arms to give up the armed
struggle to return to a civil society
and to pledge their allegiance to the
Afghan state and the Afghan government
we've seen in many parts of the world
this take place most prominently in our
own hemisphere in Colombia where over
40,000 I believe paramilitary forces
from the left and right have have put
down their arms over the last four or
five years and have come back to
civilian life peacefully largely but not
solely in Colombia and so if that's
possible in Afghanistan to work with the
rank and file then obviously one should
look at it very carefully the Afghan
authority should look at it
but I wouldn't suggest and I wouldn't
support at this point talking to the
leadership of the Taliban but basically
nation building is still an important
component of winning and I'm gannis
tonight it is I'm afraid that the phrase
is out of vogue yes but I think
nation-building is important what it
means is that for the most part when
we're dealing with very highly complex
problems in rural states with very poor
infrastructure like Afghanistan we
cannot rely in the military alone
despite their best efforts to resolve
these intractable problems we have to
look to the type of measures education
and literacy programs and food programs
and infrastructure development to help
average people to help poor people get
back in their feet and have some hope
for the future if that's what nation
building is that I'm for it and I think
we should speak more clearly here in the
United States I you know they're there
are some people in our political system
who think that nation building is
somehow a product of failures from times
past I don't necessarily agree i think
it's the hard work that we need to be
engaged in as an international community
to help fight poverty and hopelessness
and to help fight the roots of terrorism
because as you suggest over the long
term we've got to go to the source of
these problems and the source of them is
to give people hope to live a better
life this giving people hope to live a
better life requires of course spending
of resources and skills you need people
to build roads yes hospitals schools
provide to have provide services and it
seems that doing that of course poses a
problem in Afghanistan because as I
understand it Pakistani military is now
beginning to say that they will not go
over to the United States if India with
its 1.2 billion dollar program of
building schools and hospitals and roads
do not stop doing so how doesn't solve
this problem I don't know if that's aI
don't know if that is Pakistani policy
but if it were to become Pakistani
policy it would be a major mistake the
fact is that you
the problems of Afghanistan are not
going to be resolved as you and I know
overnight it's going to take many many
years to rebuild the infrastructure of
the country to reopen all the schools
that need to be reopened to allow young
girls to go to school the TallyMan
doesn't want that to happen to allow
people to begin to take back control of
their lives become productive as farmers
or a small business people people need
hope to do that and they need money to
do that they need foreign assistance to
do that and we should be engaged in that
kind of enterprise I don't I think we
can afford to turn down assistance from
great countries like India India India
is has a major role to play in
Afghanistan through all the efforts that
you suggest it and i think the indian
role in helping afghan villagers and
helping the Afghan government has been
very positive and so I don't think we're
in a position to say this country cannot
participate in the rebuilding of
Afghanistan because of differences
between Pakistan and India I think that
would be a grave mistake and India needs
needs to be given its place to work
alongside the rest of us to help the
Afghan people turning to Pakistan what
can the United States do to bring they
say some modicum of stability and reduce
the threat of terrorism that is growing
in Pakistan every day what what can you
guys do well certainly it's primarily
going to be up to the Pakistani people
in the Pakistani leadership to regain
control of their country and to regain
some forward momentum in trying to stem
the tide of terrorism terrorist groups
inside Pakistan itself indigenous groups
largely and and to return law and order
to the country we know country outside
pakistan can do that for the Pakistani
people but we can be good friends and I
think that you know Pakistan's in a time
of great need and of great crisis and so
it needs constant support from its
friends like the United States and what
President Obama's administration has
been talking about is a continuation of
the military assistance to the Pakistani
military to fight the terrorist groups
which of course is vital but also to
increase economic aid
particularly in those parts of Pakistan
that have find the greatest levels of
poverty and the greatest levels of
terrorism it seems to me that that's a
positive approach of course the test of
it will be in the implementation of
these programs but I think President
Obama has been right to suggest that
this more comprehensive approach in
Pakistan must take place I think
obviously the Pakistani government is
going to have to find a way to be more
effective in fighting terrorism the fact
that the Taliban has had fill full
freedom of action in major parts of the
border areas inside Pakistan the fact
that al-qaeda appears to have found a
sanctuary inside Pakistan is really
reprehensible it cannot be in a
long-term interest of Pakistan to see
that situation continue and so I know
that the Pakistani government has many
many problems before it but this problem
of security of taking back control of
their own country and in preventing
those terrorist groups from doing harm
to Pakistanis as well as to Afghans
across the border and to the foreign
militaries they're there to protect
Afghanistan that's a very tall high
priority and the Pakistani government
simply has to find a better way of
toward success to move to for the
neighbor India you signed you actually
negotiated and you want to lead
negotiator in signing this indo-us civil
nuclear agreement from the light of what
has happened since the agreement was
signed and actually signed into law by
president bush now what has been the
development on that score we know I when
one looks at South Asia these days is
not hard to find problems Afghanistan
Pakistan Sri Lanka and Nepal Bangladesh
but there's a bright spot called India
I'm very bullish about the future of us
relations with India India is a great
democracy 714 million people are
eligible to vote this month and next in
the world's greatest and largest
election the Indian elections are two
countries the US and India
for quite a long time now for the better
part of the last 15 years have been
embarked on this process of trying to
build a big relationship and a positive
one in education we have more Indian
students in the United States and any
other group of students now in
agriculture we're both great
agricultural countries we have a history
of cooperation we need to further that
in space and space research in high tech
where hyderabad and bungalow are such
important partners of Silicon Valley and
Route 128 in Boston so there's a lot
that we can be doing the civil nuclear
accord I don't think we ever believed it
was going to happen like the way it did
like it did but it became a symbolic
centerpiece of this new relationship we
never thought in starting it they would
become the most important and most
visible of the issues but it did become
that simple because the relish cause of
the US sanctions against India for all
these years that was a kind of real
point of bitterness in the relationship
otherwise which was growing so the civil
nuclear agreement removed that
contentious issue from the Aleutian ship
is that is that what you I think so it
was the elephant in the room we all knew
it and in 2005 when Secretary of State
Condoleezza Rice came back from her
first visit to Delhi she had seen Prime
Minister Manmohan Singh she she decided
that we would go forward and negotiate
the civil nuclear treaty effectively to
end the American sanctions on India and
to try to end the international
sanctions on India it was a very tall
order i frankly did not was not quite
certain when we began negotiating the
treaty I was the lead American negotiate
that we could be successful but we were
and in the process I dealt with two
extraordinary Indian diplomats
ambassador Shawn Shawn an ambassador
Shankar Menon we developed trust we
developed a strategic direction for how
to get this how to accomplish this major
undertaking and we we brought our two
governments much more closely together
there was this an ominous situation
anomalous where India was abiding by the
rules of the international
non-proliferation regime but kept
outside the system because of
transgressions in the nineteen seventy
when you said abiding by the rules
meaning India was not engaging in
selling nuclear technology to
is that exactly right Newton India had
been a good steward of its own nuclear
materials and fissile material it wasn't
selling those materials on the
international black market as
unfortunately other countries had done
including Pakistan through the AQ Khan
network and so we felt that India as the
soon-to-be largest country in the world
had to be brought back into the center
of that non-proliferation regime in
order to modernize it and strengthen it
it was a great battle there was a great
human cry from members of the
non-proliferation think tank community
and the United States there was a very
polluted Congress on this because you
know seen as rewarding a bad behavior
India has flouted the international
community by testing nuclear device and
the United States is rewarding it by
signing this deal and we saw it
differently we saw it as recognizing
that India of course was never going to
go back to a pre nuclear age we weren't
assisting India's nuclear weapons
program whatsoever in fact we built a
very strong wall separating American
assistance the civil nuclear sector and
no American assistance to the nuclear
weapons sector but India have been
abiding by the rules of the
international community on that civil
nuclear side in terms of civil nuclear
power plant construction control of
materials and we thought to have a
largest country in the world when India
tape open takes China it will be the
largest country in the world in
population outside the system
fundamentally weak in the system and
that we had to move on to try to work
with India for the creation of safe and
reliable civil nuclear reactors in the
country that is badly in need of greater
energy supply and at a time when all of
us are trying to face climate change and
coal burning societies like India and
the United States are part of the
problem and we need to be what we both
need to reconfigure our energy grids so
there are a lot of reasons why we went
for this it was an astounding success we
had major roles in the US Congress in
favor how did you persuade this very
skeptical Congress and skeptical and
nuclear non-proliferation supporters to
actually support this bill it was a
highly complex and esoteric agreement
of pages in length and and so we had to
if he put all the plans together the
separation plans and the agreements so
we had to in essence make this very
difficult argument that the conventional
approach to India had not worked over 35
years that there was a better way to
work with India it would not recognize
India as a nuclear weapons power it
would help India on the civil nuclear
side and I think that argument became
not only implausible but it became a
successful argument to the great
majority of members of Congress both in
the Senate and the House of
Representatives so it was good to see
that this relationship between the u.s.
and India has bipartisan support among
Republicans and Democrats in the US and
between the Congress party and the BJP
party the two major parties in India
that's the source of real strength as we
move ahead in this relationship and
despite all the problems in South Asia I
think that President Obama has a major
opportunity to continue at President
Clinton and President George W Bush both
succeeded in doing and that's building a
stronger relationship with India both in
economics trade technology and science
and also in military cooperation I don't
believe we're ever going to be allies
formal treaty allies with India the way
we are with Japan or Germany but we will
certainly be close partners and that
bodes well for stability in South Asia
as well as East Asia so what does this
military cooperation implies is it a
naval air land what kind of cooperation
it's you know it for a good 10 years now
they've been a series of a cooperation
in air and on the sea to make sure the
two militaries can work together when
they need to we had to do it we had to
work together on December 26 2004 when
the tsunami had hit so violently so
brutally Southeast Asia and subcontinent
and the Indian and American Japanese an
Australian military's work together very
well to rush relief supplies to the
affected populations there's a very good
example we're in the wake of a natural
catastrophe our two countries can use
our military forces for peaceful
purposes and it seems to me that India
the United State
have large congruent interests for
promotion of democracy and the success
of democracy worldwide were the two
largest democratic countries in the
world for stability in South Asia
India's region but also globally and
obviously the Indian Ocean is going to
be as well as the Far East will be a
source of hopefully stability in the
future not instability and if it is to
be so then we have to rely on Indian
American cooperation in part to make
that happen Robert Kaplan has written a
terrific new article in Atlantic
magazine about the future of the Indian
Ocean i recommend it to you and your
readers and he tries to think through
some of the challenges that we're going
to face in balancing China and India the
United States Japan Australia all these
countries that will play a role in the
future of the Indian Ocean in the Far
East and i think that the u.s. the
indian cooperation can be a very
positive element in that well on that
positive note thank you very much for
speaking with us a muscle burns thank
you now it's been a pleasure to be here
thank you